hay que factorizar cuatro y cuadrada más
cuatro y menos quince y bueno cuando
tenemos algo al lado de la ye cuadrada
que en este caso es cuatro algo que no
sea uno entonces pensamos en
factorización por agrupación en este
vídeo lo que voy a hacer es factorizar
esta expresión por agrupación y bueno
para esto lo primero que hay que hacer
es buscar dos números que en su
multiplicación me dé la multiplicación
de 4 por 15 así que déjame ponerlo aquí
en orden son dos números tales que su
producto me tiene que dar cuatro por
menos 15 es decir el primer el
coeficiente por el último y esto pues me
da menos 60 y la suma de estos dos
mismos números me tienen que dar 4 este
4 de aquí y bueno ya que tengo estas dos
ecuaciones planteadas aquí lo que tengo
que hacer es resolverlas pensar en dos
números que su multiplicación de menos
60 y sumamente 4 y lo primero que quiero
que veamos es que este menos 60 es
negativo por lo tanto uno de éstos
tienen que ser positivo y el otro tiene
que ser negativo y además me voy a
buscar dos números que no estén muy
alejados porque su diferencia me tiene
que quedar 4
voy a pensar primero en 5 y 12 en 5
positivo y 12 negativo cuando lo sumo
obtengo el resultado menos 7 y si pongo
al revés los signos obtengo del
resultado 7 por lo tanto aunque 5 por 12
60 estos no son los que quiero vamos a
fijarnos con 6 menos 10 estos dos me dan
de suma menos 4 pero si el cambio de
signo me dan del resultado 4 que es
justo lo que quiero menos 6 por 10 me da
menos 60 mientras que por otra parte
menos seis más 10 me da cuatro positivo
por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es poner
estos dos aquí en medio es decir en
lugar de poner 4 james lo voy a escribir
con menos seis y diez bien entonces
déjame ponerlo aquí este lo voy a poner
como menos 6 + 10 james porque date
cuenta que menos es quien más dirige es
lo mismo que 4 y es justo para eso que
me sirven estos dos valores que estaban
buscando y bueno aquí me queda cuatro ya
cuadrada y al final me queda menos 15
date cuenta que puse el 10 llega al lado
del -15 porque me va a ser más fácil
factorizar 10
en -15 y por otra parte de cuatro y de
cuadrada en 167 porque en este momento
es cuando empieza la factorización por
agrupación para actualización por la
agrupación me refiero a tomarme estos
dos primeros términos que tengo aquí y
de aquí factorizar lo más que se pueda
de cuatro y de cuadrada menos 6 james lo
más que se puede factorizar es un 2 112
que a su vez multiplicar pues a todo el
gen y después a menos 3 si te das cuenta
210 por 2 james me da 4 cuadrado y 2 ya
por menos 3 me da menos 6 10 bueno esta
es la primera parte de la factorización
por agrupación es lo que estamos
haciendo es contar en grupos
toda esta expresión para factorizar la y
ahora me voy a fijar en el segundo grupo
me voy a tomar los siguientes dos
términos y de aquí voy a actualizar lo
más que se pueda y lo más que se puede
10 menos 15 es un 5 entonces 5 que va a
multiplicar a y dice de entre 5 es lo
mismo que dos y menos 15 entre 5 es lo
mismo que en menos 3 y bueno lo padre de
factorización por agrupación es que si
esta expresión tiene factorización
entonces me van a quedar aquí
un factor común el factor común en este
caso es don jaime 3 date cuenta que
tanto esta expresión como esa presión
tienen dos menos tres por lo tanto voy a
sacar este dos días menos tres que en
primer lugar va a multiplicar ha estado
siempre a este de aquí este dossier y
después va a multiplicar a este 5 que
tengo acá y ya está la verdad es que no
hay mucha magia en esto al final lo
único que estoy haciendo es sacar este 2
y en menos 3 y ponerlo al principio como
si fuera mi factor común y después
fijarme a quién está multiplicando el 2
10 menos 3 y entonces me queda que la
factorización de 4 y cuadrada más 4 y
menos 15 es dossier menos 3 que
multiplica a 2 yemas 5